so packe ich den hut drauf kennst du
eigentlich habe ich noch beck gelöst
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen in folge 70 der zug
jetzt schon erscheint die letzte folge
die wir jetzt so zu zweit aufnehmen
werden
da wahrscheinlich schon wieder wir haben
natürlich nicht gesehen aber ich denke
dass viele den kommentaren meinen jetzt
noch die tv show ihr seid zwar zweiter
wird der mann gast und so als wenn uns
jetzt einfach gedacht ja kommen fünf
folgen wir beiden alleine passt scho wir
haben ein bisschen was hier rum geguckt
hat ein bisschen was von der welt
gesehen das wollte ich natürlich mal
sehen und dann in der nächsten folge der
gäste zu gast
aber man sieht ja auch wie bei normalen
taste castingshows ist also was heißt
eigentlich keine castingshow aber dass
die künstler sehr darauf festgelegt sind
auf dieses besseling und ist gar nicht
mehr so als normale rapper wahrgenommen
werden oder wenn der die nun mal eine
normale platte machen dann das niemand
interessiert also oder der weniger so
wenn zb battle bei basti jetzt eine
normale platte macht dann ist das doch
eine platte gemacht dass ich denke ich
glaub ich hab mich somit kommen ja und
das interessiert dann wenn wir weniger
weil nur dieses mal mehr betteln so ja
man muss es immer doppelt sagen damit
sein mehr bedeutet als postillon ja
keine ahnung also du meinst dass man die
die battle rapper dann auch als bester
rapper ansieht und da dass die nur in
die kategorie battle rap dann in das
genre eingestuft werden
ja das ist natürlich blöd aber das liegt
aber weniger am vbt sondern an der
allgemeinen menschheit oder youtube
community oder ja doch eher allgemeine
menschheit das ist jetzt nachteil
und das wollte ich nur dazu an mehr also
ich weiß von 3+ ich weiß ja für den
kennst ja kann ich
er hat auch eine eigene platte gemacht
wie zum beispiel was war das sommer
sommer winter rapsöl wird da hieß das
lied
allerdings glaube ich so und das hat
auch schon
lohnen aufrufe glaube ich aber man sieht
ja auch immer krasser librettist auch
bei youtube hochgeladen werden die flick
liegt das auch wirklich hat er lieder
wie zb das weekend finale ging bett über
passt ihre gründer glaube ich mit dabei
auch schon zwei millionen aufrufe oder
so also das ist schon heftig was da für
ein bekanntheitsgrad ist und ich finde
es auch eigentlich jetzt gar nicht so
schlimm wie du das meinst dass das halt
als battle rap angesehen wird weil die
leute die das machen das sind nummer
battle rap und ich glaube wenn sie das
schlimm finden oder so dann hätten sie
sich auch dann nicht dafür entschieden
weil das ist eher die logische
konsequenz daraus wenn sie damit machen
und was man ja auch damit rhein fließen
könnte sag ich mal ist ja studiums blog
battle können wir auch mal drüber
quatschen finde ich ja der größte mist
auf erden weil er macht da einfach nur
wenige ab klatsche vom vom vbc macht es
genau gleich genau gleichauf
der unterschied ist nur dass alle videos
auf seinem kanal hochgeladen werden das
heißt er knüpft sich den ganzen film ab
und also nicht den fans sondern er nimmt
sich da die ganzen klicks einfach und
pater logischerweise werbung drauf und
verdient sich daran dumm und dämlich an
der arbeit von den anderen leuten und
das witzige ist ja auch dass er dann
einfach zusatz regeln erfindet er der
gibt dann anfangen regelwerke vor und
meint dann nachher ja ich schmeiß den
jetzt trotzdem raus und lasst den
fortune da weiterkommen und gibt dem
asiaten 13 punkte weniger weil das ist
ja kein rap das ist ja einfach nur video
und dehnen lässt sich dann doch nochmal
weiterkommen dann gebe ich den mal
daumen hoch denke ich dann darunter das
war das größte dann wo er dann einen
video wirklichen daumen hoch gegeben hat
was dabei ihm in der quali dabei war so
dass alle seine zuschauer dann auch
gesehen haben dass er den daumen hoch
begeben hat also regelwerk julians blogs
ist auf jeden fall ganz unter aller sau
und das ich finde ich jetzt einfach nur
ein billiger abklatsch von vw tvb an
sich finde ich eine super idee aber wie
das da gefällt wird von julian das finde
ich richtig mies
ja ja ich finde es einfach einem café
das mit einem eigenen kanal hochgeladen
werden mit werbung drauf und alm und
dann und dann erzählte auch verlieren
dann erzählt nichts von irgendein
gewinne versierte plötzlicher vorteil
hat letztes mal 700 euro bekommen
warum 700 euro an warum gerade beim 16
700 euro beim ich 1000 euro sonne oder
weil ebenfalls eine gerade zahl oder so
sondern und warum normalerweise sagt man
auch vater ist vor dem turnier der
gewinner bekommt 700 euro aber um 700
euro hat irgendwie grad 700 euro übrig
gehabt oder oder soja kommt es ist
wieder das ministerium julians blog also
wie gar keinen sinn aber stört
anscheinend nur wenige oder
die größte zuschauerschaft hat keine
eigene meinung sondern klappert das noch
was bühne meint das ist einfach so das
war auch so als ist ja wohl hoffentlich
läuft komplett falsch dahin muss ich
laufen stimmt was man was man damals
minecraft ab ich bin irgendwie belassen
serverbrowser war keine ahnung warum ich
wieder drin hatte auf meinem schweizer
gar keine ahnung was war nochmal z
etwa 200 also 260 70 entlassen dieser
folge schaffte gegen schmeckendes 1300
das sollte uns einfach geradeaus laufen
sprinten haben kann und tun würde man
innerlich habe die übrigen 100 estate
hre frei gemacht ja schrecklich nicht
bringt das jetzt wenn wir zwei haben sie
schön aus essen oxidieren
wir könnten uns einfach auch nur einen
raum machen wo wir inzwischen
rheinländer und und ein bisschen
obsidian ist auch schwul oder nicht
okay ich habe gerne ein in meinem haus
und anstatt es hier immer zu einem
zentralen punkt laufen müssen glaube ich
meinen eigenen verzauberung tisch dann
das sind immerhin diamanten so viele
haben von diamanten noch nicht wo ich
den scheiß jetzt hin man also das erst
mal vorbei die idee cool und block
abgedriftet to dance blog wette muss
muss ich schauen was sich daraus
entwickelt aber ich finde ja cancel
programms das den von ihm finde ich gut
finde ich auch selbst das beschreibt das
eigentlich alles relativ genau also die
herzliche landrover jetzt der revolution
bewerbung anführungszeichen firmen teams
blog battle 2013 video zu früh
zu spät und zu oft als also keine ahnung
finde ich eigentlich sehr witziger
größeren verbänden der verein holen
würde ihr euch von dort wo geil ich
nehme mir jetzt einfach mit rein
alles wird die teure und was mir lieb
ist hier ein amt bevor das haus bis klar
ich doch alles von case pamic halten
wenn ich was mache ich nach seinem haus
an der allgemein da noch die zwei
diamanten ja manchmal nicht gefunden
hätte aber ich habe ich keine gefunden
habe ich so noch mal welche und dann
bekommst du das einfach nur du hast du
da prozent welche gefunden
das ist ja meine auf nach bisher ja ich
dass man nachher an habe ich gesucht
aber leider nichts gefunden ist aber der
ich bin auf dem weg
ich sehe nur ca 600
ich habe hier so viel war hatte ich zwar
- 100 jahre und etwa 280 ungefähr gut
ich bin dabei x100 z500 okay wir noch im
weg
und ich sehe nun erst jetzt das erste
land dass du bist gern zahlen gewesen
war
also die meiste zeit war solo im video
zu früher immer zu spät und so oft also
solltet ihr schon jetzt nehme ich habe
noch ein bisschen level verzaubert mit
bogen genau das lässt mich verarschen
was x100 doch konzept und z ist 280 ach
so ich dachte das ist doch ein stück
weit davon
die nacht ist vorbei die sich einem mops
was tust du der mann ich weiß wie so ein
wechsel scheiße schlaf ein
warum patrol postings bekommen laufen
wir nicht mal spinnen rum mensch bin sie
mit einem schlag toten keine wolken in
minecraft gutes wetter
eine was das denn bitte ihr mann in
ordnung das kann ich nicht unterstützen
müssen ich scheiße ist ob man keinem und
daher
ich bin jetzt level 13 ich falls den
stollen fluss da hierdurch die wälder
lange spot media
ich bin viel zu schnell ich bin
entspannt
ich habe nun genau 15 minuten gebraucht
bis ich wieder zu hause bin so weit weg
dass ihr mann gefunden na ja wir können
dann wenigstens magazin ist mir die
kommentare schreiben was ich denn
verzaubern soll bald 14 habe ich mich
schon wieder
und 20 ein örtlicher bogen verzaubern
ach wir wollten ja nochmal was wieder in
die tonne nur dort hat er mir nichts
zurück getan hat das gefühl die erzählen
mir einmal die luft gesprengt
der innerlich auf harschen worte sicher
von a nach b
keller wehrt ja auch kein einziges
werkzeug in die auffahrt ich wette der
partie ausgelobt mit werkzeugen
ach wer wegen gebannt haben was für ein
scheiß man hätte alle werkzeuge inventar
scheiße bisschen in meiner wohnung
das heißt ich muss jetzt einmal
werkzeuge machen ach du bist schon zu
hause erinnert sich ein täter weil er
hier weil es draußen regnet und der
markt gar nicht muss auch verstehen
speck bitte wo ist sogar noch eisen drin
hast du mir schon wieder sachen muss
meiner katze genommen nein habe ich
nicht
ich habe jetzt eine diana chester ist
rein getan
es muss auch mal wieder gesagt werden
handy hat mir gerade eine
benachrichtigung gesendet dass ich
morgen einen englischtest schreibe macht
ein handy ist so intelligent und
eloquent
ich hab nicht mal holzkisten tun für den
nächsten gast was wird der nächste wer
wird der nächste gast sein was wird der
nächste gast sein könnte ja schon mal in
die kommentare schreiben und raten
raten
dann schauen wir uns die zuschauer raten
an
bisher wurde jeder gast vorhergesagt
viele freie ob der ist der erste als das
ist erst haben wir jedes eigentlich was
heißt denn using 3 hast du den griff
bekommen das heißt das dass du mehr von
der drop in die monster was hast du noch
ich habe ich habe blut in zwei ich hab
so bücher ja gefunden
dafür braucht man aber ein amboss dafür
wollen wir ganz ganz viel eisen sollten
einfach wie vielleicht hast du dann
nehme ich von uns beiden bereiche sind
damals ein amboss genug für füße haben
einen stack oder am besten noch mehr
weil der zweite dann ja wir brauchen
mehr als ein steak doch was braucht mehr
als 16 man braucht diesen blöcken jedoch
nicht leicht wenn man braucht also ein
blogger trotzdem war nicht mehr als 161
schon schauen wo man ja
ich glaube aber auch 66 blöcke muss ich
das habe ich glaube schon
ja habe ich man gibt junge mann passt
gerade bekommen die erfahrung dass man
offen
anscheinend geht ein amboss irgendwie
nicht so selten an boston bitte des
warschauer amboss minecraft definitiv
blockieren
ja die habe ich schon gemacht ich hätte
gedacht also so geht wie ich es gemacht
habe aber anscheinend nicht aber wir
werden es sehen
aber wenn man so oft einfach wird drei
blöcke zurück annika noch mehr zurück
reichte vorher nur zwei stück habe ich
hier und da 1 21 23
die beiden jetzt habe ich einen wohl
soll dahin hat man jetzt genau einer
rezepte gepaart ist jetzt im moment
vorbei er geht damit mit oben drei
blöcke voll und dann unten so ein tisch
sozusagen ständer dafür hier mit dark
matter
da liegt am boden du kannst in dem wohin
bei der wahl zauberte schon bei mir dann
kannst du den haben ok ich muss ja sagen
dieser vorgang sei freundschaftlich und
voll so verbindet die schlagt euch gar
nicht für mich vor kkr haut euch mal
mehr so hab ich da rennst du eigentlich
habe ich einen look back du lässt dich
du lässt dich immer sofort noch einmal
ich möchte dass einmal testen
okay ich bin ja nicht das nichts
besonderes bei dir man wenn ich dich
aber starke dann bremst das jetzt
beziehungsweise würden nicht gelöst was
auf und verkauft ich habe nicht gesehen
dass ich gespannt wie man hört das aber
weil du halt bald regnet ok meine lieben
freunde dann tue ich jetzt einfach jetzt
am ende dieser aufnahme das nehme ich
jetzt nicht mehr auf aber dann packe ich
einmal die sachen von und in der kiste
länderchefs rein
dann ziehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
die data den kontostand was sie denkt
wie der nächste gast sein wird
30 folgen noch bis zur folge hunderte
etwas geldes kommen einen moment lang
ihr alles verraten hatte man einst und
jetzt und und und und lippenstift und
fertig erzählen dank fürs zuschauen ein
bisschen diesmal macht